talking trash is like a little bit it
almost belittles what you were doing
because you have a master plan and then
you executed it to Perfection I
appreciate that unbelievable it's
important I start doing a little
research into this and it looks like you
have this understanding of how to build
a fight that is a little bit different
than other people who have built fights
brilliantly I think there are people who
build fights right because whatever
happened in their life they developed
this defense mechanism that made them a
heel or a face it just is what it is
that's who they are and you strike me as
someone who kind of analyze what a heel
is what a face is and then worked out
what you have to do to execute both
these things is that true yes yes I call
it the art of the bad guy okay this is a
book yeah yeah when is when does this
begin that you start realizing as even
as as a kid you know I watch these
fights with my dad and Sugar Ray Leonard
was real big back then that was that's
my favorite fighter ever but just to
talk to you know like an era and then we
came through the the Mike Tyson air of
course and you read about the Muhammad
Ali here but it was just one of these
things when my dad and I was sitting
around and we would talk about the
fighters that we wanted to see yeah and
you know it wasn't just the guy with the
good Cross or the the powerful jab it
wasn't like that it was a guy that could
entertain it was a guy that could tell a
story that would would bring us along a
journey not not just you had to be
undefeated and that was a real big thing
in boxing they didn't know how to make a
star if they couldn't control this the
script yeah it was it was one of those
really tough things and Vince McMahon
himself said that he said you cannot
create a star if you can't control the
outcome events was was looking to even
purchase the UFC at one point and he he
passed on it for that very reason and
but I remember that quote I remember
when Shane McMahon said that that's what
his dad said I only share that with you
because you know I just think there's a
story there I remember being in in the
third grade and Mrs Stanford tells our
whole classroom to to tell a story you
have to have five W's who what when why
and where and a great promoter is just a
great Storyteller a great fight is it's
nothing more than it has a great story
it never has to do with this guy's a
champion or this guy's undefeated no big
fight has ever been based on that it's a
good story and I just noticed that a lot
of guys don't know the five W's when
they tell a story okay so every fight
that you're going into every fight that
you want you start pointing out the five
W's that's right who what when why and
where in in a really important one is
why and that's a real tough one a lot of
guys are fighting you know it used to be
really important that you had a good
fighter I mean your village or your
tribe I mean they would come they your
women steal your stuff take your land it
used to be actually important to have
somebody that could fight amongst you
and it becomes less important what
happens now if you lose a fight a little
prestige a little money so somebody
throws a belt out there it's one day
about 100 years ago some guy throws a
belt out there and he sells a bunch of
tickets to Madison Square Garden now
they're fighting over this belt yeah but
you have to be fighting over something
it's the reason I give you that history
lesson you there it has to be for
something and sometimes these guys are
fighting there's no purpose on it
there's no contendership there's no
ranking there's no ego there's no Pride
and they don't understand it's their job
to tell the story it's up to you to
build the person man you have these
these guys in the fake tough guy
business I've never been around a bigger
bunch of fake tough guys than in an MMA
locker room
oh yeah with microphones going on
they're so tough and they'll do this and
that you need a guy like Dana White or
Scott Cook goes in the back and tries to
get a contract signed and they won't do
it they got to talk about talking meet
with my managers and I need more money
it's just it's one of these really more
things then you only get three fights a
Year by the way I mean I've taken on
three guys in one day these punks want
three fights in a year and you can't get
them to show up to it it's a very
bizarre time and what are you fighting
for I think that that's the most
important thing that you got to tell the
audience and so many people they don't
want to be booed they're they're a bunch
of bad guys largely I mean bad people go
into cage fighting you're right take
your shirt off and beat a guy but a
steel cage for some money in the
Applause of a drunken audience you're
probably not a really good person to
start with
I wanted to think that they're this
educating this smart guy and I I just
never understood the concept man you're
you're a dirty rotten cage fighter just
like me yeah but one of us will admit it
and one of us won't and you know these
guys can't take the hits man they can't
take the booze and the booze could be in
the form of a tweet that comes out as
against them that would be they can't
take it now the ones that can take it
make a lot of money that's really yeah
now when do you realize that that's
where the money is very early on like
high school yes okay additionally sorry
when did you realize you can take it
because that's a rare thing it's like it
is really yeah well the world changed
you know we you can take in the hallways
at high school is a little bit you know
in your hometown paper is right but once
the internet comes out and people can
take these shots that's a very different
thing yeah how you want to manipulate
that how you want to manufacture it and
they all want it they can't take the
booze and it is just always surprised me
that they pretend that this is a nice
thing or guys say I I can't wait to
fight you you know it's such an honor
why would you beat somebody up that you
have honor for why would you beat
somebody after two weeks it's just a
really weird concept to try to tell the
audience you know I just like him so
much I can't wait to take my fish and
drive it into his head I mean I've heard
people say that actual quote then smile
and it's like man just turn this guy off
let me just let me find anybody else
other than this it's a boring guy there
was that Conor uh Poirier fight sure
where I think it was two where Kano was
really nice and he was like and you know
I'm gonna donate to your you know
where's the YMCA and I'm going to help
you with the hot sauce and do these
things and it was like there was part of
you it's like okay this is new and kind
of Novel for for for Connor but at the
same time as like the stakes aren't that
high for this fight right and then three
of course where he's going absolutely
crazy you know your wife's in my DM he's
like sure everybody that was a wild time
right I agree with you
yeah I remember when he was doing that
nice guy stuff I'm gonna donate what do
you think that was about well I like it
if he was doing it to be condescending
if he's doing it like I've got so much
money I can even help you that I'm into
the whole thing but if you're doing it
because you know you got put in the
paper for getting caught you know
beating up a girl and snorting coke and
so you're trying to repair your image
it's like man don't be a punk sometimes
just be who you are that's all that I'm
suggesting the audience is going to see
through a fake so if you're you know you
want to be that nice guy but the
audience can tell you're acting you're
you're beat okay were you surprised when
you tried to play up the heel and then
the audience started to love the heel
yes
so you were ready for the onslaught of
criticism and hate and then for whatever
[__] reason yes they love you it did
become a problem it did become a problem
where it was anti-what I was doing I
went and did a show called The Ultimate
Fighter in Brazil but they wanted to
kill me in Brazil at that time this is
fantastic yeah they really wanted me
dead though I I had a six-man armed
security for everywhere I went we're in
bulletproof cars
yeah it was after that yeah
it makes sense kind of Justified play
this video this
this is my favorite piece of trash talk
in fight Sports
there's nothing better I was in Las
Vegas when the noguera brothers first
touched down in America
there was a bus that this is a true
story there was a bus that pulled up to
a red light and little nog tried to feed
it a carrot while big nog was petting it
he thought it was a horse this really
happened
not really
a carrot and now you're telling me that
country has computers I wouldn't know
that
I did not know that
do you remember when I said he fed the
bus a carrot were you even listening is
this thing on is this on and then the
other one was petting the bus saying
whoa he thought it was a horse and now
you're telling me they have computers in
Brazil That's crazy to me what was your
question
it makes sense it makes sense I
appreciate that I appreciate you giving
me homage to this stuff and tell me that
you that you enjoyed it I don't know
that anybody else has ever told me no I
mean the whole thing was scripted the
whole thing was planned in my own mind
but that had never been done before like
Ariel doesn't know how to respond that
is very normal today when that piece was
done that was done in Las Vegas the
executive director at the time tried to
pull my license when he found out that I
did that in Nevada he decided he had
jurisdiction over that he tried to pull
my license and I was in the room when he
told the Renzo fertility that Dana White
he said can kids are going to look up to
this guy and this is not what I want
kids to be like I use no profanity I
made no threats I've never used a
four-letter word I've been called the
greatest sha t-talker in all the sport
but I've never used profanity this guy
was going to pull my license because he
marked out for the gimmick so much he
thought I was such a bad guy and I was
doing such bad things and I claimed this
guy didn't know the difference between a
horse and a bus and and uh you know he's
got kids and what can he think of that
yeah he tried to pull my life stuff that
was bad but you guys getting in the ring
and almost killing ones the government
official that oversees fist fighting in
a steel cage
by the way he didn't get my license
because that would have required a
hearing but they did stop me from the
opportunity wow I had a really hard time
getting through to this guy because he I
mean he just fell for it so much I would
come to his way and I would come to he'd
be disgusted with me yeah that was there
a little part of you when you saw him
that pissed off yes did you go oh this
fight's good 100 100 no I knew what I
was trying to get but this was the part
that was the problem or you asked me
sometimes when I when I was being a heel
but then they ended up cheering for me
that what when I wouldn't get the
response that I was looking for it would
throw me out foreign like how far can I
go I don't I don't know what else to do
within my own code you know I had to
code too I wasn't gonna threaten a gun
that's very important
that's right what is the code of the
heel I think that you have to
established to the audience if you're an
anti-hero what your code is but then you
must fiercely adhere to that code
whether you're right or wrong whether
it's within the rules or even within
laws if it's your code and you will back
your own code and my whole I would say
whatever I wanted about a guy but no
matter what any guy any weight class at
any night I would show up it would not
matter how sick I was I would leave that
locker room on time every time I have
never missed a competition I've been
doing this since I was nine years old
but that was part of the code if you
said it you've got to go answer for it
if you've got no professional town no
profanity part of the specific reason
for that no I just didn't like it I I
just didn't think it was uh I thought
there wasn't a creativeness to it
a bad guy yeah when you're not I don't
know if that's accurate or not but this
is but this is only someone a [__]
[__] isn't as bad as saying he tried
to feed a bus again yes I would agree
with that yes
one is a very clear negativity another
one is bringing a negative energy
without the negativity you know it gets
a little bit more complex now do you
find out that people love humor so much
that it doesn't matter how mean you are
as long as you make them laugh they'll
love you that was a lot of truth that
was a lot of Truth as long as they would
have fun and I did find out through the
process that this is a journey you know
I used to think he had to be undefeated
he had to be the world champion but you
don't if you can get people to come
along if for whatever reason that just
changes the story and it shifts over
here and and so I would have those
planned I would have speeches planned in
my head that I was going to say to Joe
Rogan after I won but I have pleaches
that if I lost two I know exactly what I
was gonna say so sorry to Andrew's
question hold on one second to that so
you planned a losing speech for fights
yeah every time even if you knew your
favorite even you knew you're gonna wax
this guy you maybe fought him once
before you sparred him you know you're
gonna beat this guy you still plan every
time do you think that messes with you
psychologically does it invite
negativity into the fight where you're
like oh I'm gonna lose I've read about
that I've heard people say
conference you must believe it I know
I never did I thought only a bully's
gonna fight a guy that he knows he can
beat I I don't know if I can beat any of
these guys I thought that was part of
the honor um and I've heard people say
that I was 100 I knew I was like man
I've never in my life I've never been
100 except for my wife I knew that was
the right girl for me but that is truly
the only thing in my life for sure the
rest of it was all a gamble yeah no two
Andrews earlier quit you planned all
this out can you walk us through when
you were like oh I can make more money
being the heel than the face and I have
what it takes to get booed and be okay
with it I just knew that there's only
there's only two characters right from
the beginning of Hall Hollywood you got
a good guy and you've got a bad guy
there isn't 500 flavors there aren't 30
other ways that you could you got a good
guy and you got a bad guy and so you
gotta you know you gotta monitor what
he's doing and then you've got to come
over the top and all the guys want to be
the good guy I mean I fought some really
bad guys before and made them look like
good guys and they loved it they
couldn't believe it oh this guy's being
the jerk and it's not me and
um yeah but one was authentic and one
wasn't I don't think that there was
anything wrong if you're gonna go fight
a guy why are you bowing to him why are
you talking about this is about honor
and respect why are you wearing your
bathrobes and talking about your belts
and pretending you can break bricks and
stuff I just thought it was weird I
don't know why these guys did this in
martial arts I think one of the great
helps to our sport that never gets
credit is actually Tank Abbott Tank
Abbott is one of the first people that
came along and said man this isn't
martial arts and it's not it's a cage
fight that's what it really is these are
a cage fighters yeah I thought there was
an honor in that I thought there was
honor in telling the truth is there
anybody you saw or you've seen since do
it at your level
oh gosh I mean I love the work of
McGregor you want to know who's very
good on the microphone and never got his
credit was Rampage Jackson no Rampage is
hilarious he was great though yeah I
mean I remember being living in rooms
and we'd be and we would sure and turn
it up and make the room go quiet after
his fights or they wonder whether he
lost we all wanted to hear what Rampage
said and I that's never happened to me
before not even in Mike Tyson fights her
Sugar Ray Leonard nobody have I been in
living rooms where we've should people
so we can hear what this guy has to say
except for Rampage hmm yeah and why do
you think even I don't know he was you
know he was charismatic he was funny but
he also had a story hit somewhere he was
going to go with absolutely no filter
that's right yeah he could say something
that would destroy his career yes almost
every time he was capable of saying
something that would destroy courage he
had the courage to say something even if
it might ruin his career yeah but he was
also a chess player you know so many
guys it's just about tonight only and
Rampage was like no tonight's gonna
leave me here I always felt like that
with Rampage so when his fights ended
before we faded a black and rolled the
credits we what was coming next I always
thought that was very smart you were
similar right soon I tried to do that I
tried to get that audience weather here
and you'll almost lay them to what comes
next